he had wanted to rebuild his reputation
but after years denying the accusations
of abuse against him today any prospect
of a return to public life for the duke
of york is over in a swift and short
statement buckingham palace said that
with the queen's approval and agreement
the duke of york's military affiliations
and royal patronages have been returned
to the queen the duke of york it said
will continue not to undertake any
public duties and is defending this case
as a private citizen well this is an
unprecedented situation
the duke of york who is the queen's
second son
at one time he was second in line to the
throne
after his elder brother the prince of
wales and for 20 years
andrew held that position
um and this is very demeaning for him
but it was very necessary andrew knew
that something had to be done
and the queen knew that too
it was becoming increasingly untenable
for the duke to hold on to his remaining
royal roles i spoke to dozens of
organizations today that had links to
the duke all of them were keen to
distance themselves from him but none of
them were keen to speak on the record i
spoke to grenadier guards who said they
felt embarrassed by the duke's links to
their regiment ultimately though it was
the queen who made the decision about
his royal and military titles
seen leaving his home in windsor great
park today behind the scenes discussions
with the royal family and advisors have
been taking place an uncomfortable
balance for the queen as mother and
monarch the decision means that the duke
of york will lose his patronages and
affiliations to charities and
organizations like nhs trusts the royal
navy officers association and the sick
kids foundation and he loses military
titles including colonel of the
grenadier guards and colonel in chief of
the royal irish regiment he will no
longer be able to use his royal highness
in an official capacity but will remain
as a duke of york i certainly think it's
the correct decision for
uh prince andrew to give up his military
honorary titles such as
deputy colonel in chief of the royal
lancers
because he's now in a situation where
his integrity is in question
and his reputation
has been damaged so much
that the soldiers sailors and airmen
and air women who are
out on operations
cannot be comfortable
in
tasting him as they might have to do at
a dinner uh or indeed
if they had to
look up to him and speak to him
the army board will be looking at this
situation all the time with a view to
does he match the
standards and the values of the armed
forces in the 21st century
and i'm afraid
he doesn't match that standard
uh after what's happened in the last
week
the duke of york spent 22 years in the
royal navy and retained a number of
honorary military titles but he was
dogged for years by his relationship
with the late billionaire jeffrey
epstein and this was a decision to
protect the royal family from a damaging
distraction in the year of the platinum
jubilee the duke has always denied the
claims that he sexually abused virginia
du frey when she was a teenager a source
close to him said that this civil case
was a marathon and not a sprint and said
the duke will continue to defend himself
but today a clear line has been drawn
between the royal family and the queen's
second son ali fortescue sky news
well let's go straight to our royal
correspondent now ran on mills and
rhiannon it's been a dramatic turnaround
in this story in the past 24 hours what
do you read into the timing of the
palace's statement and who do you think
is behind this decision
oh you could not have had a more
dramatic change in the past 24 hours
from the palace saying they simply
weren't going to comment then this shock
statement effectively drawing a line
under prince andrew's royal role no
longer officially an hrh so who made the
decision in the end well the queen may
be head of the institution but i
understand that this was widely
discussed within the family the
statement itself is quite interesting it
doesn't make clear whether actually
prince andrew himself said that he would
hand over those titles again i suspect
that's unlikely one thing i suspect is
likely is that prince charles and prince
william were probably heavily involved
in this decision after all they are
increasingly taking on roles on behalf
the queen and they are just as invested
as she is when it comes to trying to
protect the raw name also within that
statement i think a very telling
sentence where it says he's now going to
defend his name as a private citizen
again i think forcing him out into the
cold in many ways saying that actually
it's time for him to face this as an
individual and not as a royal as we had
a potential trial at the end of the year
also though i think why now why do this
now because yes of course the judge's
decision yesterday was very significant
but the allegations against prince
andrew have been the same for a number
of years but i get the sense that within
the palace there was a belief that
actually the fact they weren't acting
was going to be more damaging in the
long run you would not want a situation
where the queen for example was having
to be advised by her prime minister or
by the cabinet that they had to that she
had to act on behalf of what her son was
doing maybe to stop any international
embarrassment and also of course don't
forget this was always going to be a
year where the royal family were going
to be in the spotlight i think they're
hoping that this will in some ways draw
a line under things as they head towards
the platinum jubilee but i think sadly
for them a story of this magnitude
is not going to go away and will
continue to cloud the run-up to those
celebrations whether they like it or not